[Music]
don't get busy keeping up with trends
buy what you like but keep it simple and
classy
i think that's an important point
because trendy simply means soon to be
out of style yep and so if you're
following a trend right now you're
following something that you'll soon
have to let go of however if you keep it
simple you keep it timeless
then you don't have to worry about what
is trendy you don't have to worry about
the logo you don't have to worry about
the shoes that are in you don't have to
worry about the shirt or the dress or
the pants that are in style because
james dean
or joan didion
they would look stylish today take a
picture of them from
whenever they were at their prime
and they would be perfectly stylish
today because it's simple yeah and it's
classy and it's not trying to follow
what someone else has said is trendy
it's funny intellectually i know
that trends will eventually
wear out
but emotionally it feels like they never
end like in la the
uh the the the tie-dye sweatpants and
tie-dye sweatshirt
like that was really popular when we
first moved here yes i think just in the
last year like i haven't seen it as much
no but i just remember thinking like
when is this freaking trend going to end
like what is up with and maybe i'm just
because i'm not cool enough to like pull
that off
what's that
yeah
you know what's timeless
a broken watch oh nice
yeah i'm cutting the mic off anytime
yeah but it's true that
the the trendiness that we seek means
we're seeking obsolescence yeah if you
are seeking to be trendy you are also
seeking to be obsolete a month from now
a year from now two years from now at
some point that trendy thing that you
bought is going to be junk in the not
too distant future that's so fascinating
man it's fascinating that
because it's such a snare it's such it's
such a scenario it's such a narrow
window
that like
you know we want to be
hip
to
that thing that isn't going to last very
long
because it is it's a um what i'm looking
for not a passive thing uh but it's an
it's an expiring thing that you know if
we're if we're hip to it during the time
that it's cool then we're cool yeah it's
in vogue and therefore it says something
about who i am yeah it goes back to that
rom dos quo we become encrusted
with our identities or by our identities
we think we are this type of person i'm
the type of person who wears tie-dye i'm
the type of person who looks stylish i'm
the type of person who would dress this
particular way and there's nothing wrong
with looking simple and classy there's
nothing wrong
with wearing something that makes you
feel like the best version of yourself
but if you're tapping into everyone
else's best version of yourself are you
really you or are you some
version of what everyone else wants you
to be right did you enjoy this
stand-alone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free